an African-American Father and Son team
here in the valley are expanding their
family business they just recently
opened their 17th McDonald's location
this one's located on Fort Apache close
to sunset in the southwest part of town
8 news now reporter Brian will sat down
with him explaining what led to their
success and what their plans are for the
future
behind me it may just look like another
McDonald's to you but this one has a
special meaning not only to the
community but to the owners behind it
but the men sitting on either side of me
I haven't really helped and help they
did Ronald Smith and his two sons Chris
and Brooks Have Been instrumental in
building this family-owned chain of
McDonald's restaurants so put the toys
in the happy meal boxes they stretch
across the valley with more than 800
employees strong and their 17th store
opening just this month
his son Chris worked his way up worked
my way from every position on the floor
to management to
here I am as a partner and owner
operator here and uh it's uh like I said
something I've never looked back on
while Brooks took a different path
forging his own business I want to get
into the more sustainability approach so
I found a business called chat value
based out of Vancouver Canada
brought them out to Las Vegas and the
sky is not the limit for what this
family will do next I never look
at where I am on the ladder
thinking to myself that this is the last
rung okay there's always more steps to
make you know whatever opportunities
presents itself
to look at it review it study it and
determine whether or not it's something
to pursue
and congrats to them Ronald Smith and
the family tell Brian they want to be an
example of what hard work and a little
bit of
a bit of for a family